mit einem der größten gefahren an
radioaktivität an sich oder solcher
strahlung dass wir sie nicht sehen und
man versucht herauszufinden wie viele
leute wirklich gestorben sind die zahlen
gehen extrem auseinander ist tatsächlich
tschernobyl mercedes galt kerntechnik
also so allgemein als sicher
diese folge wissenschaftler reagieren
ist ein kleiner blick in die
vergangenheit der dreh für diese folge
ist inzwischen ziemlich genau zwei jahre
her kurz danach hat uns die korona
pandemie erreicht weswegen wir damals
spontan ungeplant und unsere erste folge
wissenschaftler reagieren zu kontern
gemacht haben danach sind die aufnahmen
dieser eigentlich ersten folge hier erst
mal im archiv verschwunden jetzt sind
wir endlich dazu gekommen uns diese
vorzunehmen das video hier ist außerdem
ein blick in die vergangenheit weil wir
uns heute mit der endspiel serie
tschernobyl beschäftigen in der serie
geht es um die ereignisse rund um das
reaktorunglück 1986 wir haben echt lange
überlegt ob es angesichts des
furchtbaren kriegs in der ukraine gerade
geschmacklos ist genau jetzt über eine
vergangene katastrophe in diesem land zu
sprechen letztendlich haben uns aber
entschieden dass vielleicht sogar genau
jetzt der richtige moment ist daran zu
erinnern und aufzuklären welche
verheerenden auswirkungen dieses unglück
hatte ähnlich wie das video damals zu
kontakten erfüllt auch diese folge hier
hoffentlich einen kleinen
bildungsauftrag zum aktuellen
weltgeschehen und falls es bisher noch
nicht klar geworden ist an der stelle
noch mal eine entsprechende twitter
warnung wir sprechen in dieser folge
über und zeigen bilder zu dingen wie
atomwaffen und strahlenkrankheit wenn
ihr also generell oder aktuell sehr
sensibel auf diese themen reagiert dann
würde ich empfehlen dieses video hier
vorerst zu stoppen heute mit dabei sind
christian altmeier eine biophysikerin
die bei uns schon mal einen auftritt im
video zu intelligenten steinpilzen hatte
und reinhard renfordt physiker den
vermutlich einige von euch aus dem
podcast methodisch incorrect kennen
die deine hand haben erst in das stück
vom reaktorkern quasi also das graphit
das halberg guss ist wo halt auch das
radioaktive material mit drin ist und
überhaupt das ist ungesund hatte ich
immer das land für mehr alleine drumrum
zu stehen ist schon sehr ungesund sind
die hand zu nehmen ist
da sehen wir auch ein effekt was
radioaktivität oder starke ionisierende
strahlung da gerade so gefährlich macht
den mensch fehlt ein sinnesorgan dafür
wir können strahlung nicht sehen nicht
spüren nicht wahrnehmen nicht riechen
gar nichts ist einfach sollte also sie
ist da wir können sie messen mit
messgeräten aber wir können sie als
mensch ohne messgerät nicht warten
trotzdem kann sie innerhalb kürzester
zeit super kasse folgen für den
menschlichen organismus haben und das
ist so ich glaube mit einem der größten
gefahren an radioaktivität an sich oder
ein solcher strahlung dass wir sie nicht
sehen können und nichts also überhaupt
nicht wahrnehmen können weil denn wenn
jetzt irgendwas info brennenden haus in
flammen steht da geht halt niemand rein
das ist das sieht man da weiß man ist
schlecht aber wenn ihr jetzt irgendwie
so einen reaktorunfall hasst man halt
überall wirklich mörder mäßig viel
strahlung ist
da passiert halt nichts also hier sieht
es jetzt vielleicht bedrohlich aus weil
alles in schutt und asche liegt und weil
es brennt aber das ist bei dem
reaktorunfall die kleinste gefahr
gewesen
eine
station im süden
[Musik]
die klassische strahlenkrankheit kann
ich mache die in verschiedenen spiel
also schweregraden verlaufen kann von
man man kurz ein bisschen viel und einem
fall die haare irgendwie auch mal kurz
noch mehr man hat eine
überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit von noch
irgendwie 90 prozent also sehr sehr gut
bis hin zu überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit
quasi null und dann gibt es da auch noch
du stirbst innerhalb von einer halben
stunde bis hin zu bestimmen in zwei
wochen sogar noch mit der erholungsphase
dabei es gibt doch zwischendurch immer
noch für die leute gedacht haben alles
wieder gut ist es auch gar nicht so
schlecht und dann die kosten sich die
seele aus dem leib die bluten wie sonst
was also innerlich und so weiter sind
dann aber auch eine platte die
eigentlich wieder ganz okay sind aber im
körper ist so viel kaputt dass der tod
quasi unausweichlich ist die strahlung
die die abbekommen der reiter für
bestrahlung ist ionisierende strahlung
das heißt die zellen werden auf
molekularer ebene kaputt gemacht es ist
nicht so dass man sich kleine partikel
vorstellen kann hier einen durchlöchern
sondern die die der aufbau der zelle wie
die zelle funktioniert und alles das
wird zerschossen dort halten molekül wo
irgendwie teile von abgerissen werden
quasi dadurch dass energie eingebracht
wird und diese überbleibsel diese
radikalen moleküle quasi sind super
reaktiv die dann mit anderen molekülen
die hat auch kapuzen letzte wieder
reagieren im grunde hämmert man quasi
den organismus auf molekularer ebene
damit und im schlimmsten fall bei viel
strahlung gibt so viel kaputt dass du
halt wir gerade schon beschrieben
entweder direkt spielst oder der woche
steht so oder so leichteren fällen wo du
das überlebt hast du immer noch ein
unglaublich erhöhtes krebsrisiko danach
weil du halt plötzlich zählen hast die
nicht mehr so funktionieren wie sie
funktionieren sollen sondern plötzlich
anfangen zu suchen oder ähnliches so
generelles problem mit der produktion
und so weiter also die folgen der
strahlenkrankheit sind gar nicht so
pauschal zu benennen weil es ist einmal
davon abhängt wie viel strahlung wie
lange also wie hoch die dosis die duh
abbekommen hat welche art von strahlung
hast du abbekommen und welcher bereich
deines körpers hat diese strahlung
abbekommen dass jeder fall im grunde ein
bisschen anders aber dass man immer
sagen kann ist ab einer gewissen dosis
die man abbekommt ist sense
gen
das ist auch so eine lustige sache wenn
man versucht herauszufinden wie viele
leute wirklich gestorben sind die zahlen
gehen extrem auseinander es gibt aber
noch russland von offizieller seite her
die sagen todesopfer 30 ein mitarbeiter
des atomkraftwerk wurde irgendwie
begraben unter diesen trümmern also
während der explosion wird der dreck
getötet leute die also tatsächlich
irgendwie ja durch so etwas wie
explosionen oder sowas zu schaden
gekommen sind wurden gezählt aber
wieviel jetzt tatsächlich an dieser
strahlung gestorben sind das finde ich
sehr spannend dass es bis heute nicht
wirklich klar
wurde jedoch schwer zu sagen also direkt
beim kraftwerk also durch den unfall an
sich ist man das selbst was ich glaub
ich gelesen habe ihm so 40 50 leute aber
selbst dies gar keine genaue zahl gibt
es heutzutage ich auch schwer aber
tatsächlich viel weniger als ich gedacht
hätte das hat mich auch überrascht aber
generell an spätfolgen was seinen leuten
gestorben ist auch durch den fallout und
also was passte alles noch
runtergekommen es vom wind verweht wurde
und so ist man glaubt es dabei um die
4000 oder sind ja das ist aber wirklich
wirklich schwer zu messen also auch bei
dem größten strahlen katastrophen die
wir sonst hatten die von menschen dabei
geführt wurden zwar die beiden
atombomben die marke geworfen wurden
auch da ist es schwierig zu sagen wie
viele menschen dadurch wirklich
gestorben sind weil einmal sind
natürlich eine menge menschen direkt
durch die explosion gestorben sowohl im
kraftwerk als auch beiden atombomben
weil der strahlungen die später für
spätfolgen verantwortlich ist ist
schwierig zu sagen haben die leute jetzt
zum beispiel krebs bekommen weil die
halt verstrahlt worden oder haben die
krebs bekommen weil es ihnen auch
anderes war oder so man kann noch häufen
wird aber man konnte man kann ja
sozusagen es gibt ja eine anzahl von
fällen die normale in der bevölkerung
also eine prävalenz irgendwie so und so
viel prozent aller menschen werden an
dem und dem tumor erkrankt und dann das
ist einfach dann die bassline und dann
guckt man wie habe ich relativ dazu eben
mehr fälle also dass ich habe immer
gedacht das dürfte doch eigentlich so
schwer sein aber das führt ja trotzdem
dazu dass keine sehr genaue zahlen
sondern relativ großen fehler mit daran
hast und dann bist du bei dem teil wen
du fragst der eine seite nimmt den
fehler gerne maximal in die eine
richtung maximal ja nicht und ich glaube
deshalb geben die zahlen
einen blick klar ein und wird schon das
14 saison ja ja so nah dran stand es
reicht also auch da schon mal so die
eingebrochene nicht mehr retten sie
können sie immerhin setzen um eine
rauchen oder so dass es gut wird das war
schon was wussten sie nimmt zu dem
zeitpunkt noch gar nicht wo ich glaube
die leute da gearbeitet haben das waren
ja kerntechniker und so dem sollte oder
dürfte durchaus bewusst gewesen sein dem
moment was wir da gesehen haben das
war's also muss ich mal überlegen wie so
ein kernreaktor funktioniert wenn man
hat da spaltbares material einer
atombombe nimmt man so viel spaltbares
material das man komprimiert das eine
kettenreaktion abläuft das alles also
wie halt ein kern zerfällt sitzt zwei
neutronen frei die spalten jeweils
wieder im kern setzt wieder zwei
neutronen frei und so weiter und so
weiter kennenlernen und in dem reaktor
mache ich das gleiche nur unter
kontrollierten bedingungen
man nimmt sich spaltbares material
packen davon relativ milden einen
reaktor zusammen aber so dass er noch
nicht kritische masse hat also noch
nicht diese kettenreaktion läuft dann
nimmt man einen moderator grafit war es
glaube ich in dem oder halt eben
schweres wasser oder so dass die
neutronen die sowieso durch die spaltung
von einzelnen spontane spontan zerfall
entstehen verlangsamen weil diese
neutronen sind relativ schnell und
wendig verlangsamt sind dann ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie einen neuen
kern spalten wieder sehr hoch und
so ein reaktor fährt man eigentlich
immer so an der schwelle zu dass das
genug kettenreaktion stattfinden dass
der halt heizt und wasser erhitzt womit
dann strom erzeugt wird aber nicht so
viel dass es halt außer kontrolle und
hier sehen wir einen brennenden reaktor
kehren das quasi da ist nichts mehr
erinnern ich nix mehr kontrolle seiner
damen im grunde also jetzt nicht nicht
eine atombombe die explosionsartig in
dem moment halt alles 3 setzt aber wo
schon die reaktion abläuft die halt so
stark und so lange brennt bis das zeug
durch ist aber bis es tatsächlich
tschernobyl passiert es kalt kerntechnik
also so im allgemeinen ja als sicher
professor liga soft ich hörte sie
erzählen gefährliche dinge sehr
gefährliche dinge dass unser reaktorkern
explodiert sein soll bitte erklären sie
mir wie kann ein r bmk reaktor
explodieren
im moment kann ich mir das selbst das
ist glaubwürdig irgendwie so die
reaktion auf so eine totale katastrophe
erst mal so ein 1 1 das kann doch gar
nicht sein so abschreiten und
dafür auch nicht sein deswegen kann es
nicht sein doch langsam wird ihnen das
klar was schlimmes passiert ist und dann
auch diese diese tapferkeit in dieser
will das dann irgendwie zu beheben also
ich finde es super gut gespielt viele
tolle bilder die man natürlich sofort
euch gesehen hat weil alles fix das war
spannend zu sehen wie sie es damals
eventuell ausgesehen hat man quasi von
oben rein gucken jetzt ist ja alles mit
beton zugeschüttet und diese sachen oben
also ich mich jetzt frage ist wie wir
das im vergleich dazu eine atombombe
aussehen und dafür haben wir auch noch
mal extra filmbereich
deswegen jones wurde von ganz gut ja ich
verstehe ich auch nicht
haltmacht stephansplatz kippen
ich wünsche mir auch den star wars immer
weitergemacht
so sehen atombombe aus
tatsächlich tun sie das gerät er jetzt
jetzt nicht generell aber eine spezielle
sagt sie ich genauso augen damit die
zahlung ist die größte von menschen
gemacht explosion die war viel zu groß
viel zu schwer um die wirklich irgendwo
hinzubringen also bevor die irgendwo
abgeworfen worden wäre denn flugzeug
schon lange abgeschlossen also es gab
ich glaube es gab nicht mal ein flugzeug
das groß genug gewesen wäre das ding zu
transportieren also weite strecken also
wir haben sie abgeworfen aber das ding
war eine machtdemonstration keine also
taktisch nicht sinnvoll also in die muss
sich jetzt vor der atombombenexplosion
schützen was machten uns aber noch 30
sekunden zeit hat wo man weiß gleich
kommt in der mengestraße vorbei antwort
[Musik]
das ist relativ realistisch vor der
eigentlichen druckwelle kommt erst das
licht und die strahlung die so hart ist
und so stark dass sie alles in brand
setzte anfang an zu brennen danach kommt
geshoppt werden und hämmert halt alles
liegt
das hat ein sprichwort liegt zwar im
juso fritsch das gibt's wieder da gibt
es manchmal lesen news fritsch ist der
moment in einem film wenn es so weit
drüber ist also wirklich so abstrus dass
man ab da alles in dem film ab da können
auch außerirdische co angenommen da ist
welche atome dessen dem bereich wo die
energie die abgestrahlt wird also das
licht noch so energiereich ist dass die
sachen einfach zu brennen meinte auch
die die häuser gesehen man so eine
atombombe hat er sowieso 20.30
megatonnen da hast du einem radius von
weil sich 20 kilometer totale zerstörung
das nichts mehr bleibt also
totalzerstörung heißt auch da bleibt
auch keinen keinen kühlschrank oder so
mehr stehen also der der wirklich mal
der wird nicht mal weg geschleudert so
sondern der ist einfach weg der ist kult
in deiner bestandteil auf dessen nix
mehr und jetzt ein bisschen spaß von
außen das schöne ist von außen
offensichtlich sehr heiß geworden ist er
mit blei ausgekleidet so alles ist das
auch so ein bisschen ihr glaubt also ja
klar schützt vor strahlung bei bleibe
also der sehr dicht ist und so und da
nicht so viel strahlung durchkommt aber
wenn du genug strahlung hast dann hast
du auch scheißegal wer braucht schon
einen halben meter blei oder so mich so
einen kühlschrank abgesehen davon dass
verglichen mit den anderen effekten die
wir gerade gesehen haben der in dem
bereich ist von dieser explosion wo er
politisiert worden wäre also der wert
komplett zerstört das haus würde auch
nicht so kaputt gehen einfach so das
wäre einfach weggeblasen man hat heute
auch wenn man damit nicht mehr so
konfrontiert wie die ihnen den
achtzigern wo wir zu hochzeiten des
kalten krieges war gar nicht mehr die
vorstellung was eine atombombe bedeutet
also eine atombombe ist nicht nur der
radioaktive fallout nachher da irgendwie
alles verstrahlt sondern einfach die
sprengkraft einer atombombe es wahnsinn
wie weit ist der weg zu drei kilometer
da wäre eigentlich da war nichts mehr da
ist nix
also sagt mega bullshit megawatt
spitzenleistung
über bullshit aber nochmal unterschied
nach tschernobyl keinen atompilz weil
keine atombombe sondern außer kontrolle
geratene kettenreaktion aber hier
atombombe atompilz also atom ist nicht
gleich atomexplosion ist nicht gleich
explosion wir lieben dank fürs zuschauen
wie immer danke schön dass ihr dabei war
ich hoffe bewegung heute einiges über
strahlung abschwung und all diese
unschönen dinge
vulva veto muss
ich habe mir mal gerne in die kommentare
welche filme wir uns noch anschauen
sollen welche computerspiele welche
serien welche teams welche blöden
aussagen von politikern worauf sollen
wir reagieren schreibt uns gerne in die
kommentare ansonsten wie mal vielen dank
fürs zuschauen und bis zum nächsten mal
bleibt neugierig erster trick